more than 6,400 firefighters are
battling California's two largest
wildfires right now fire crews have
faced five of the 10 most destructive
fires in state history in the past 13
months DeMarco Morgan is in Paradise
California with the personal toll for
the men and the women on the frontlines
DeMarco good morning Gail good morning
to you we have seen the devastating
pictures coming out of paradise but I
want you to take a look at this right
here this was the home that once
belonged to Cal Fire captain Joe Chavez
you can see it's in complete ruins you
can barely even make out the layout of
the place and after speaking with
several firefighters on yesterday many
of them who have been fighting fires
across the state for the past couple of
months this is proof that it's taking
more than just a physical toll on their
bodies it's dinner time at this cAL FIRE
command center in Chico California a
chance for firefighters here to slow
down I'm baby
for Chad Farris it's a time to see his
infant daughter's face I got out of
military last June started the next day
with Liberty and being on fires ever
since Farris is just one of the
thousands of firefighters battling
flames across the state during a year in
which fires chewed through more than 1.5
million acres of land an area larger
than Rhode Island fire seasons don't
seem to end these days Ben Holliday and
Joshua Wilkins have been moving from
fire to fire since June I hit all the
major fires in California and then
figured you know come November we'd be
done it's a lot you know family life is
very difficult personal life is
difficult and just you know our personal
well-being is is stressed by the job we
do both men are from Butte County where
the camp fire has devastated their
community this is our own we both
everyone on our task force that we're on
has family here a house is gone and
whatnot so yeah this one definitely at
home more than any fire I've ever been
on
hands down I pulled into our driveway
and our house was on fire
CalFire captain Joe Chavis helped his
wife and two young daughters evacuate
before watching his home in Paradise
burned down that was definitely hard to
watch and and there's still a lot of
feelings I needed to deal with with that
I'm just glad to have my family whole
because there's a lot of families out
there that are not whole right now
there's a lot of people that still
haven't been found knowing that there
are people out there that don't have a
family anymore
that hurts we're so grateful for all of
the firefighters out there risking their
lives to save and protect all of us out
here and it is worth noting that there
are so many of them working around the
clock that there are reportedly 1500
inmates prison inmates also working in
the field and they are reportedly being
paid $2 an hour but we are grateful
again grateful for everyone's job and
sacrifice out of here
Bojana in a moment of crisis people
really coming together and it's
important that we did this piece to
honor these firefighters to mark oh
thank you